brought to you by The Witcher Wild Hunt
available may 19th hey guys and welcome
to reality check I am NOT cam sorry
about that
but to ease the transition I thought I'd
take on one of his favorite game series
The Witcher as the basis for this week's
episode the conclusion to CD Projekt
Reds high fantasy trilogy managed to
score the perfect 10 from gamespot own
Kevin Van odd who praised it's absorbing
story fantastic attention to detail and
it's phenomenal open-world but just how
big is the land of tameria well
according to CDP it is 20 percent bigger
than Skyrim's vast expanse and it's 35
times bigger than the witcher 2 oh and
that big open world comes without
loading screens so how have CD Projekt
RED managed to make the witcher 3 so
huge well the short answer is technology
and a smart use of level design I'm not
gonna get bogged down in the
technicalities in this episode but part
of the reason why we can get open-world
games as big as the witcher's is due to
technology more RAM and faster
processors give developers better and
faster ways of accessing game files like
artwork and sound meaning that really
long load screens are slowly dying out
well I did say slowly so how are open
world games usually made well technology
is only part of the answer it's not just
one big map that loads at once
rather it's chunks of the map stitched
together while you're playing the game
loads your immediate surroundings to its
memory but what about the area you've
just passed through well if it hung
about it would just clog up valuable
memory so it gets dumped this process of
feeding in new and pushing out old data
is called streaming and it's the reason
why you don't get a load screen while
scrambling around levels of course it's
not quite as simple as that have you
ever wondered why your characters
movement is forcibly slowed to a crawl
in certain areas almost some buildings
are just laid out really weirdly and
have so many
or even why a character randomly needs
to squeeze through small cracks in the
environment
well that's because streaming has its
own memory limitations the most insanely
detailed and vast areas of land tend to
take longer to load so to hide this
level designers use choke points to give
the game a bit more time engines like
epics new unreal for help to circumvent
this problem with the new world
composition tech instead of breaking up
the world into little chunks its levels
of detail that get streamed in and out
as needed it's a tool that developer
Jaeger famed for tricking you into
shelling innocence with white phosphorus
in spec ops the line have been working
with for two years in order to recreate
the city of Los Angeles for Dead Island
2 but The Witcher 3 was developed in CD
Projekt words custom-made red engine 3
which was specifically designed for
these vast open-world environments they
completely rewrote the streaming system
that they used for the witcher 2
obviously because that game wasn't
open-world at all it was a series of
enclosed areas separated by our old
friends loading screens when the jump to
open-world the new system needed to be
able to load resources in such a way
that Geralt can walk freely from one end
of the map to the other without
encountering a single load screen the
problem being is that there's just an
incredible amount of audio and visual
assets to load like music artwork and
the game's logic meaning that the meager
memory offerings of the Xbox 360 and the
PlayStation 3 just didn't cut it this is
why there's no last gen version of the
game and it's even why companies like
Yuba soft are going to be current gen
only from now on apart from just dance
that's never going away
and while previous red engines were
portable across both 32 and 64-bit
operating systems red engine 3 is 64-bit
only this extra processing power and
memory usage means that more assets can
be loaded at the same time which means
we see way more of the map and we don't
get stuck all of those loading screens
this was a very top line look at how
open-world games in this current
generation are able to be so much bigger
and more detailed than in the last over
the next few weeks I'm gonna be taking a
really in-depth look and how
technological advances are able to
change gaming as we know it game changes
if you'll pardon the expression in the
meantime you can catch me on Twitter
at Lucy James games and I'll see you
next time